but first the number of people killed in
earthquakes in turkey and Syria has
risen to nearly 50 000 nearly 8 000
aftershocks have been felt since the
first large Tremors two weeks ago and in
Syria nearly 6 000 people have died and
millions are homeless many in both
countries are concerned there could be
more earthquakes to come Sami zaidan is
joining us now from Adana in Turkey
Asami what are you seeing where you are
well what we're seeing is an effort now
to try and deal with the many people who
are displaced and today they kick off
the first phase of this container cities
project they're aiming to get people
into fifteen thousand containers out of
tents they're also working on prefab
homes and I can tell you Doreen as we've
been driving on the highways over the
last few days we've seen sometimes
Columns of trucks carrying these prefab
homes heading to some of the hardest hit
areas so they're trying to do what they
can to get people out of very unstable
living conditions into something more
settled and help like that just can't
come soon enough if you listen to what
the United Nations is saying they're
saying one and a half million people
have become homeless in southern turkey
because of the earthquakes they say half
a million new homes need to be rebuilt
and they say 200 up to 210 million tons
of rubble needs to be cleared up well
just to get give you a size of what
we're talking about that's enough to
fill 30 square kilometers full of rubble
well talking about Rubble we've been
covering the rubble we've been covering
people being pulled out alive from the
rubble I caught up with one family that
has a heart-wrenching and heart warming
story an incredible story they film
themselves under the rubble assuming
they were going to die they wanted to
send a message to the world
a message and a call for help for others
outside of the rubble
the family is pinned down by collapsed
concrete struggling to breathe
if we die and this phone is found
there are five of us here under the
rubble of this massive earthquake
they decide to film what they believe
are their final moments but this is not
the incredible story of their survival
this is the incredible story of their
selflessness
whoever finds this phone please help me
fulfill my promises to people please
give Mustafa 2500 liras and give ahmed's
children the orphans 5 000 liras please
paid to them on my behalf
the family had collected donations and
were worried the money in their
apartment wouldn't make it to the needy
this is what's left of what the Kurt
family once called home
the powerful earthquake reduced an
entire compound of towers to dust
underneath Fatma Adel and their three
children endured 10 hours of agony
incredibly they were rescued alive all
except the youngest son Bilal
his mother filmed him playing with his
brother before the quake in what would
become his final moments
we heard the Tremor in the early hours
of the morning the building shook are
into the children and my wife followed I
called out
and he looked at me but before I could
pull him out the building collapsed on
us surviving an earthquake and then
surviving being trapped under the rubble
of your own home that's an unimaginable
ordeal but then walking above that
Rubble that can be painful too
sure we're looking for bilal's things
his clothes or books I had a son here he
talked laughed and slept here
when you're walking on top of your past
each footstep forwards takes you
backwards it's very difficult to be here
it's bringing back bad memories
each scoop raises hopes
each item uncovered pulls at the heart
suddenly a mother is confronted with
what she sought but didn't desire her
dead son's shirt
some food and tea can fill the void of
hunger but not the emptiness of losing a
son so you're in the middle of an
earthquake why were you thinking about
charity for others I mean that's a
beautiful thing but most people would be
worried about themselves
because the money was for Orphans people
trusted me with their money the story of
the Kurt family has spread in turkia
prompting donations to the orphans Fatma
was so worried about under the rubble
who could stay comfort in knowing that
through their actions the ordeal that
ended bilal's life has started a new
chapter in the lives of others
incredible story there and a lot of
needs her for shelter for medical
attention for food and so on we can go
now to Theresa Beau she's live for us
from Hasa in hatai that's one of the
hardest hit areas too and Teresa you've
been looking at medical needs there what
do they look like
well family wherever you look all around
this area there is so much suffering so
much need we're now here in Hasa this is
located in the hatai province this is
just one of the 11 provinces affected by
this earthquake we're now in this tent
city where several people there's
hundreds of them living here their homes
have either been destroyed or others are
very much afraid of going back to their
homes that have been damaged because of
the aftershocks that are still ongoing
uh you're Distributing Aid and food and
water and shelter is a priority for
humanitarian organizations but treating
the injured treating those who have
fallen ill because of of this earthquake
is also a priority Rubble as you were
mentioning earlier today is is a problem
for many of the people we have spoken to
respiratory problems so we're right here
where Indonesia has also set up a field
Hospital they're treating lots of people
here we're going to talk now to Dr
Corona rinta one he he's been in several
natural disasters All Around the World
in Nepal in Indonesia so many other
places what can you tell us of what
you've been seeing here right now yeah
I've been seeing a lot of Victim Because
of the earthquake damage but after the
first week of the earthquake damage so
the problem has become changing from the
injury to the infection so now the
infection cases is becoming more and
more and they're coming to our medical
camp one of the things we're seeing is
Rubble everywhere we go destroyed homes
destroyed hospitals destroyed schools
what impact does this Rubble have on on
people's Health around this area yeah uh
of course because of the rubble so the
government trying to uh clean it up and
then the death has become the next
problem because that is uh various uh
smooth and then they can be uh
inhaled by the the people so there must
be some causes for the respiratory
problem one of the things we're seeing
are people living in tents it's very
very cold at night you know are you
seeing people treating people of you
know cold common colds that could get
more complicated with time there's not
enough Health Care
uh the haircut I think is quite enough
but of course the climate is you know
like uh if you see that there's a
extreme climate in here minus two
degrees Celsius at night and down so it
becomes worsening the the problem that
the people uh
thank you very much
so as you were mentioning earlier lots
of rubble some people estimate that over
200 million tons of rubble will have to
be removed from this part of the country
and what to do with it is also a big big
questions and and when you walk around
as I said before there is need there's
lots of people that are desperate to go
back and find a place to live lots of
people that have been left vulnerable
because they have lost their homes they
have lost their belongings they do not
have a way of making a living and
humanitarian organizations right now are
also extremely concerned about women and
young girls we've been talking to many
of them many pregnant women who do not
know where they're going to end up
delivering their babies
foreign
and without a home
she has been living in a tent in
shanlurfa since the earthquake destroyed
her house two weeks ago
a refugee from the war in Syria she has
been living in Turkey for five years
I am looking for a place to rest and
hopefully hospitals will be in a good
condition we hope the situation will get
better I'm pregnant and the situation is
difficult for everyone
the U.N says over 1.5 million houses
have been destroyed and many of the
victims are now living in camps like
this one
Healthcare is a major concern for
humanitarian organizations especially
among women thousands of them are
expected to give birth in the next
months and many hospitals around this
area have been destroyed and that's why
it is a concern that they'll be able to
do it in a safe way
the United Nations has deployed doctors
and nurses intent camps to check on how
women are coping with a disaster
had her baby two weeks ago and is also
living in a tent
we are scared and cannot go back to our
home because it is all damaged it's warm
here and better for the baby
they're also providing women with
medication and treatments some are at
risk of miscarriage
the U.N is estimating at least 25 000
births in the next month
unfortunately many of the health places
were either destructed or they are not
in or they are not operating at the
moment but what we are doing within our
capacity as unfpa is job supporting
working together with Ministry of Health
to ensure that sexual reproductive
Health Services continue we need
urgently to provide mobile storage
clinics and other support services for
to ensure women and girls access to
these services
the Turkish government has promised to
fast-track rebuilding but until that
happens there are hundreds of thousands
of vulnerable people who have been left
without a home
less
well these scenes of Devastation and
need of course getting attention from
people in cities which are no strangers
to earthquakes right around the world
including of course
istanbula reports now on how people are
concerned there
a Race Against Time for these building
inspectors they're scanning for cracks
or poor foundations then they'll decide
which buildings to demolish and which
should be repaired City officials warned
a few days ago that 90 000 buildings
could collapse if an earthquake hits
Istanbul Pune
an earthquake in Istanbul will affect
four and a half million people this is a
top priority for us and should be seen
as a national security matter it has to
be taken to the highest level yeah
bought his house three years ago but he
doesn't know whether the building is
earthquake proof Levant is among a
growing number of people who no longer
feel safe in Istanbul yeah
I'm not planning to live longer in
Istanbul eventually I will have to leave
for another place I'm thinking about
taking my family to a safer City
Istanbul sits not far from the north
Anatolian fault
seismologist
the worst Asian side is very safe in
terms of ground conditions
and also the housings are relatively new
in the Asian site and but if you go to
European site only the safe place for
the ground conditions are the northern
part as people in the South struggle to
cope with the aftermath of this month's
powerful earthquakes people living in
Istanbul fear the next one
for many years seismologists have been
warning of an earthquake that predict
could cause widespread destruction in
Istanbul this is an overcrowded City and
a big tourist attraction and many people
are worried they want to know whether
they're buildings and their City are
strong enough to withstand a major quake
and prevent loss of life
Istanbul
well it's not only the temperature and
the weather now that's heating up as the
whole aftermath situation intensifies
people's sense of confidence people's
sense of security in some places is
drying up as the riverbeds behind me I'm
going to hand you back now to Doreen in
Doha so I mean thank you so much for
that reporting from Adana in Turkey